one last quick note before we have a go
at this question the key thing that
often makes people confused about these
things over here or helps you know is
what people get wrong is which one's
negative which one's negative because
beyond a CoA they have this nut order to
them how do you remember that the sum is
minus Mione and the product is Co now
what did we do this morning to create
these results to derive them what did we
do yeah we were we were looking at
coefficients we said here's a quadratic
here's the same quadratic from another
angle let's see what happens if we play
with these right and that's exactly what
we did we got these results okay but
there are other ways to do this because
we actually know for any quadratic what
the two roots are we have a whole
formula for this what's it called it's
called a quadratic formula right now if
the quadratic formula gives us the roots
I'm gonna squeeze this in over here then
one of the roots should be minus B plus
or minus what square root of okay I'm
lazy so I'm just gonna break that okay
all on to a that's one of the roots
isn't it if that's one then the other
one must be oh sorry that's one of them
that's because I just want one right the
other one must be the plus do you agree
so that's this guy over here now these
look like a mess to deal with
okay but if all you're doing is adding
and subtracting this is actually really
nice because the relationship between
these two they have a name they don't
know what these are called when one's a
minus and ones a plus starts with a see
you haven't thought about it these are
called conjugates right now one of the
reasons why these guys have a special
name why they're called conjugates is
because when you put them together they
interact in very nicely simple ways
watch let's have a look you can write
this with me because it's that simple
right alpha plus beta because you're
adding these things together what
happens bless you to this square root
part what happens when you add these two
things together
they're gonna cancel out this is just
like solving a set of simultaneous
equations by elimination isn't it these
things are going to eliminate so all you
get left with is minus B on to a plus
minus B on to a the the square root of
the discriminant both going they've
canceled each other out well this is
clearly look what happens right well
this is minus B on a do you agree the
same thing happens when you do the
product it looks like it's going to be
disastrous but remember they have
conjugates so we should have some faith
that this is going to come out nicely in
the wash right this is gonna be this guy
and this guy on the top what's gonna be
on the bottom for a squared right cuz 2a
times 2a now again this looks terrible
but hold on they're conjugates so what
happens to these guys what what is this
what is this some a factorization of
this is difference of squares isn't it
so what's the first thing what's the
first square it'll be B squared right
that's that's the square of this thing
here then I'm going to take away this
squared yeah which is just this on this
are you with me so far but you know what
the discriminant is don't you the
discriminant is b squared minus 4ac just
watch out but there's a negative there
so this is actually a double negative
are you okay with that
you see I'm just yeah all over 4 a
square well this is just canceled city
isn't it watch cancel cancel cancel
cancel and there's your C on a just like
we proved this morning okay so if you
have trouble remembering which one is
which actually doesn't even take that
much thought I just wanted to show you
it's another way of getting to the same
thing it really as soon as you get to
this line here when you're like oh I'm
adding these things in they're both
negative well clearly that gives you the
negative 1 so e sin Syrian correct but I
want you to know them like you shouldn't
need to look at the region
take that time to look at it before that
okay last example wanting to have a go I
don't think anyone's up to this are they
no okay
except for Jason okay good that's fine
let's quickly have a go at this so
everyone can write this down this is
question 16 so it's buried a little bit
toward the end of the exercise but it's
easy enough to do okay now in all of
these contexts I've sort of just been
assuming let's just call a root alpha
and beta okay I don't know anything
about them and so I just sort of define
them independently but often you get
given information where you know one
root is related to the other one so you
don't just give them random letters you
can say I don't need so many pretty
rules I can have them dependent on each
other so for this question I would say
let the roots be alpha and now instead
of saying beta I know that beta will be
double the other one so I'm just going
to call it two alpha just as equally I
could have called it alpha on to yeah
because one would still be double the
other why am i avoiding that because I
don't like fractions so this is just
fine okay sometimes you can't avoid
fractions but this time I will so if the
roots are alpha and two alpha I can find
the sum of roots just like I normally do
with minus B on a yeah it's just it's
not alpha beta its alpha plus 2 alpha so
what's this equal to minus B on a in
this case is negative 6 that's good so
you can see here I can already work out
what alpha is that's nice isn't it 3
alpha equals negative 6 so alpha is
equal to okay excuse me now I didn't
even tell you what the question was
didn't even tell you what the question
was we just started to launch into this
which is not that bad a strategy you
always certainly have to do something
with these results if they say something
like this okay but now you can see if I
go to the next step here's some of roots
product of roots will be alpha times 2
alpha it's not it's not better is it
what is the number going to be in this
case it's
see on a which in this case is and as so
happens the question is asking us to
find em so we get over here to alpha
squared so all you need to do is pop
this in and it looks to me like M will
be 2 times 4 which is 8 does that make
sense so just define appropriately like
so based on whatever information the
question supplies to you we could have
said 1 root is one unit away from the
other room if one group was one unit
away from the other root then you would
define them as alpha and alpha plus 1 or
just as easily alpha minus 1 they're
still the new 1 unit part what if one
root word the reciprocal of the other
you would define them as alpha and so
you just to find them however the
language of the question tells you to
okay